l'équivalent d'un mois de ventes en
seulement quatre jours après le
déconfinement les français se sont rués
sur les rollers à moyen de profiter des
beaux jours
mais surtout en période de crise
sanitaire un moyen de se déplacer tout
en évitant les transports en commun les
rollers comme moyen de locomotion
c'est assez récent car au départ c'est
avant tout un sport et on appelait ça le
patin à roulettes exemple en 1943
[Musique]
pratique très populaire le patin à
roulettes tombe doucement dans l'oubli
et dans les années 80 le voile a
ressuscité avec un nom plus in
officiellement on appelle ça le roller
skate mais on dit généralement le relais
roues le skate le roller skate et flashy
il permet de faire des figures ou même
d'aller danser alors une mode
parions plutôt pour une nouvelle
activité de loisir une des rares notons
le au passage à ne pas consommer de
pétrole
dans les années 90 c'est le roller blade
entendait le patin en ligne qui déboule
en france il a quelques adeptes mais
c'est bien lors de la grève de 1995 que
ses ventes se sont envolées
parmi les moyens utilisés par les non
grévistes qui veulent se rendre à leur
travail les a bien sûr la marche à pied
mais aussi le vélo et les patins à
roulettes
pas de transport métro et bus à l'arrêt
embouteillages monstres le roller se
présente comme la solution pour se
déplacer rapidement
depuis mardi cette grande surface du
sport augmenter ses ventes en rollers et
en vélo de 30 voire 45 % certains jours
pour certains la grève n'a fait
qu'accélérer une envie déjà ancien pour
d'autres c'était le déclic imprévu il
n'y avait pas d'autre solution
et même après les grèves certains reste
perché sur les voleurs à la fin des
années 90 le roller est en passe de
devenir un véhicule à part entière à tel
point que ses adeptes réclament un
statut afin de pouvoir circuler sur la
route tout comme les cyclistes
moi je survis 62 par le centre de paris
je prends plus jamais ma voiture je suis
toujours en roller mais à partir des
années 2000 la frénésie du roller va
retomber
ce magasin spécialisé vend près de 4000
paires par an ce trois fois moins qu'en
95 années ou le roller a envahi la
capitale
aujourd'hui le roller semble être une
nouvelle fois ressuscitées rapide écolo
un peu casse cou mais sans risque de se
le faire voler contrairement aux vélos
[Musique]